CASPAR HARE: Is there a God?
You may well have an answer
to that question.
Most people have an answer
This is a matter of religion.
Now ask yourself do you
know you're right?
Could you persuade a reasonable
person that you're right?
To answer these questions, we need an
understanding of what it is to know
something, and of when it is reasonable
to believe something.
And then we are doing philosophy.
My name Caspar Hare, and I teach
introductory philosophy here at MIT.
In this course we'll cover several
big topics in philosophy.
We begin with knowledge and God,
as I alluded to earlier.
We'll then move to talking
about consciousness.
Some things are conscious.
Some things aren't.
You're watching this on a
machine of some kind.
I don't exactly know what.
It isn't conscious.
You are conscious.
What's the difference between a thing
that's conscious, like you, and a
thing that isn't, like your machine?
We'll then move to talking
about free will.
Some things have free will.
You have free will, or at
least you think you do.
But how exactly can you have free will,
given that the matter in your
body is pushed around by the immutable
iron laws of physics?
And finally, we'll talk
about identity.
What sort of a thing are you?
What is the basis of your
identity over time?
These questions have been discussed in
some form or other for thousands of
years by many great thinkers.
We will read some of the great thinkers
in this course and try to
draw from them.
Our aim is not to celebrate and
appreciate and applaud these thinkers,
but to use the insights
that they give us.
The activity here is active
and not passive.
This is the MIT way of
doing philosophy.
Thousands of students here at MIT have
taken the course, although it's
available here online
for the first time.
STUDENT 1: So probably the three words
that I would use to describe this
course to a friend is
really stimulating.
It's really deep, because we cover
a lot of really important issues.
And also, it's quite comprehensive,
because we cover a lot of really
fundamental topics in philosophy.
STUDENT 2: You go to class and you
listen to the lecture, and it's not
even a lecture where you take notes.
It's a lecture where you become engaged
in the material and engaged in
what he's teaching, because
it matters to you.
STUDENT 1: One of the main reasons why
should take this course is because you
get to have a debate on these issues
that are really fun to talk about.
STUDENT 2: Professor Hare
is just amazing.
He really is.
And you always hear, oh, the
professor makes the class.
And this is absolutely true of 24.00.
CASPAR HARE: I hope that this course
will help you to become a better
thinker, more accurate, more
disciplined, and more creative.